i remember when i first got to mit and i
was so excited to see the truly
cutting-edge work being done in robotics
you know the robots that we've been told
over and over again are going to take
everyone's jobs and take over the world
and i quickly discovered that there's a
massive discrepancy between the public
perception of where the world is in
robotics and where we actually are so
from what i've seen trust me
for most robots if you ever feel
threatened you can just dump a bucket of
water over them and you should be
absolutely fine
now that's not to say that we shouldn't
be thinking about
what robots mean for the future of work
for the future of humanity that's
something that i think about a lot
i just come at it from a slightly
different perspective on our future and
that starts with a unique aspect of
robots that i'm especially interested in
which is our self-projection
for example something that i think is
fascinating is the fact that there's a
japanese manufacturing company
that will have its employees do
exercises in the morning to warm up
their bodies for their day on the
assembly line
and this company which also has robots
working in the factory will have the
robots do the same exercises with their
arms in order to be perceived more like
colleagues and less as machines
isn't that a little bit weird
or i think it's interesting that when
boston dynamics released the following
video
everyone in robotics watched this video
and said wow the robot didn't fall over
but then there were quite a lot of other
people who watched this who expressed
more
negative emotions about what was
happening in the video and it actually
got to the point where peta the animal
rights organization was getting so many
phone calls that they had to issue a
press statement
now peta didn't really care much about
this they said they weren't going to
lose any sleep over this because it
wasn't a real dog
but i'm interested in this i am
interested in the fact that despite all
knowledge to the contrary
people will consciously or
subconsciously treat robots like living
things
you